こんにちははじめ雪方ですというわけで
ちょっとまだ
のととか微妙なんですけどもとりあえず
ネッツは落ちたんで
国家つしました
とりあえず曲したんですけどもそれだと
思う
それじゃあのまだ病み上がりなると珍しく
ねぇちょっと死ぬかなぁと思った経験をし
た
動画のタイトルにもあるようにですねあの
ただの熱じゃなかったみたいなんですよな
のであのサウナでぺちゃくちゃしゃべって
いたの大学生集団たちの政治はないとは岩
と岩ねメッツニュースで賑わって始めたと
サラダで大切っているみたいなニュースと
なってたんですけど許したわけじゃない
からね賛否両論みたいに書いてありました
けど俺はマジで起こっているか風邪ひいて
も引かなくてもお店のルールで黙って入る
書いてあるのに喋ってるのはそれは
100%違う悪いから許したつもりじゃ
ないんですけどもそれプラスなんか別の
議員とかながいろいろあってよく4日か5
日5日間くらいかな実は毎日39度以上の
熱が出てて1日ぐらいの三重苦度だったら
全然おり耐えれるんですよ今までの人生で
もなんかいあったしたんじゅくドグラ1日
パンくらいだったら余裕でしょと思ったん
ですけど34日間続いた時に何か一
サービスに
あれなんかいつものネット違うなあと2日
目ぐらいから2日目くらいからちょっと
なんか危機を感じて体のあ多分これ死ぬ奴
だなと思って夜中に救急センターに運んで
もらってなんか見てもらったんですけど
そのときはなんか普通のただの
熱ただの風邪ですみたいな感じでその解熱
剤とか色々貰って帰ってきて
しっかり飲んであったまって寝て起きたん
ですけども朝起きてもう1回熱測ったら
40度くらいやって
あっ
あまってくれ本当にやばい一だと思って
普通じゃないことに僕そこで気付いて
トレーダーの病院に行ったんですけどもそ
したらもうなんかやっぱり俺もさあその
水風呂で冷えてねだと思い込んでたから
原因が分からなくて水お医者さんと
いろんなことを話して話してる時はもう
40近くあるからもう意識ないんですよっ
て血液型さ中でうちに取られるんですけど
も
過呼吸みたいな手で
寝たままでは大丈夫です血液なんか決意に
めっちゃ取られていた培養培養検査みたい
なからすごい精密日を調べる検査をした
結果
なんと
感染症だったことが分かりました
拍手するところじゃないんですけども原因
がわかったことは本当に俺にとっては
プラスだったこれだったので見たいなのが
わかったので何かわけのわからんウイルス
とかヴィジュアル系に反して2回とも陰性
だったんですよ実はこれなーとかだったら
すごい周りの人に迷惑かけるとかで嫌だっ
たんでインフルでもなくコルナでも中で
感染症っていう血液がなら以上の異常な値
を占めしてたらしくて病院に行ったんです
けどとりあえずもうねぇ
3日間何も食べれなくてとりあえず点滴
打ってねもうぶっ倒れできるっていただい
て何とか多少なりとも元気になったんです
けどもで僕なんかすごいいろいろ考えたん
ですよ何か他に心とであったっけと思って
いろいろ考えたんですけどもなかなかただ
の風邪でさん突く度がその産業化が続く
ことも考えられにくいしなんか別の何かが
あるけど最近何かありましたら聞かれた時
俺くんって僕思い出しちゃったんですよ
最近なんからー
太ももかゆいなととも痒いなと思ってあの
お医者様に太もも見せたんですよ見ます
太ももあーこっからドイツを一蘭2位でし
たも苦手な方は苦手だと思うんですけども
けっこうすごい量で自分もちょっと苦手な
んで集合体があるから俺もちょっと見るの
は強いんですよね重宝優勝増だというので
ちょっとご覧くださいどうぞ
さあっ
僕の
東毛にあたります今も治りかけのニキビ
みたいになってるんですけどもうちょっと
苦労あたかったんですよね今だいぶ pp
ようになってきましたけどこれ俺の圧勝足
客側も結構刺されててこんな感じになって
ますあとねこういう家も求めちゃされて
ますフジツボみたいになっちゃっていいよ
ねこれは倍増お医者さん曰くこれだとは
言い切れないんですけどこれ何かといい
ますと
大外に
かまれているんですよ
団に俺最近やばいんだっけだダニに咬ま
れるなんてなかなかないんですけどどうし
たんだろうなパンツの中でた大暴れしてた
んでしょうねだけが実はこれあの見せない
んですけど外ままだけじゃなくて一応
太ももで821と旧30カ所刺されてて
あと実はこうも飼われてるんですよこの3
箇所くらい噛まれててレイパーなんかその
事か太ももの内側リンパが通ってる部分
って炎症が起きるとすっごい体に何か影響
が出るらしくてでお医者さんの見解による
とまぁそのダニ媒介の感染症をこっから
ウケちゃって感染症になっちゃったって
いう流れらしいですあの安心してください
ヒトからヒトに打つんないらしいのであと
まで谷から僕が貰っちゃっただけで僕から
これが誰かに移ってことは基本的にないと
いうことだしです幹線そうですって年か
調べたら調べたらというかお医者さんから
聞いたんですけどもこのなんか39度近く
の高熱が1週間ぐらい続くって言われてり
2処方箋とかその中対症療法を薬でてねが
早めによってツイッターはしたんですけど
もまだ喉とかすごいたくて捕まえまで
うどんも食べなかったんですよと言った
すぎてネック久々にア
俺死ぬなってくらいの高熱が
4日間くらい続きましたどっこでだに拾っ
てきたんやろ戻るならお医者さんもこれが
原因ですって言いきらなかったしいろんな
要因があるんですよ体が悪くなるって本当
にこれからみたいな感じだったよお医者
さんもメガの原因は分からないんですけど
とりあえず感染症にかかっているという
ことだけは事実としてあったみたいです
たぶんこれだろうね一つはこれ+やっぱさ
の水風呂とかでた胃腸が弱ってガッと放熱
になっちゃったという説はありますまあ
日々の疲れとはねまぁいろんな要因がある
んですけども何ねぇ俺山とかで覗くとして
ないっていうなよ新居とかにひょっとし
たら何が入ったのかもしれないんでわかん
ないね家の中にいないと思うんですけど
もうちょっと皆さんもぜひ気を付けて
下さいコロナとかインフルとかだけがない
からね怖いのは vivid どこかで
多分何が俺のパンツに入ってきて案2の中
で大暴れ知って出て行ったんですよでここ
が膝と言って噛まれちゃってパンツで暴れ
た後にで偽バニー膝なんとほっぺ上げて
飛んでって帰っちゃったみたいという説は
僕の中であるんですけども
と強いを噛まれた場所も悪い子ね大下に強
いっすよまじでそういうしばらくは何か見
づらいバー
のぞ飛んで5がひどかったですね
つらかった今も熱は下がらずけどだけ
なんかまだガラガラしててすごい嫌なん
ですけどもう本当になら30クドある突起
に比べたらマジでも生きてる感覚が
ハッピーというか無性を実感する4日間
でした本当にで何かお医者に聞いたんです
けどもだに入ってんのわかんないか死な
ないらしくて暑さに弱いんですけどもなん
かお風呂入ったりしただけだ前段に知ら
ないらしいんですよだからなんか
織さらないったと言ったじゃないですか
あれ
ワンちゃん正しかった雪はあるみたいです
結構ダニ退治の作戦としてはすごいあり
たってみたいなのでな自然にいいことして
たみたいという結果でしたちょっとね俺も
ビビったなんかも2キロ痩せた真央4日間
続くためが合併症とかさ中耳炎なんか耳が
痛くなったりとかも結構して色々と本当に
何が身の危険を感じた4日間でした何かあ
[音楽]
ダサいダサいけど原因がわかっても何より
です皆さんところのとかインフの声です
けどもそれ以外にもかなり危険な病気とか
検証とかも世の中にありますのでそうなら
ないように作っいろんなこういうこと
たくさんあるから気をつけて皆さんに来て
くださいあの無事何とか12月には体調
復活したので頑張ります
pou
dou
[音楽]
douあっちょ